en el vídeo anterior hablé sobre
curvatura y el radio en la curvatura y
la descripción que hice fue puramente
geométrica te dije que imaginar así en
tu coche por algún camino y tu volante
llega al límite de lo que puede girar
entonces se detiene y entonces al pasar
eso tú empiezas a formar un círculo con
el coche y te preguntas cuál es el radio
del círculo que formaste ahora para
simbolizar la curvatura usamos el
símbolo especial capa minúscula que es
igual a 1 sobre radio y esto es así
porque tú quieres una capa que simboliza
una curvatura grande que corresponda a
un giro brusco un giro brusco es
simbolizado con un radio pequeño pero
una curvatura grande ahora como
describimos esto en una manera más
matemática bueno vamos a ver esto y para
describir una curva si haces una
descripción paramétrica entonces tendrás
una función s
que toma un parámetro t
y te da las coordenadas x si cada una
como función de t entonces tienes x dt y
quiérete ahora en este caso la curva que
yo dibujé s paramétrica de la siguiente
manera en la componente de la función x
tenemos de menos seno de t y en la
componente de la función ya tenemos uno
menos coseno de t esa es la curva que yo
dibujé así se parametrizar y esto quiere
decir que para cada valor te obtienes un
vector que cae sobre la curva y mientras
éste va variando también cambia el
vector que obtienes ajá pero pero la
punta del rector va trazando la curva
como un todo el vector va dibujando la
curva mientras te va variando y la
matemática que hay detrás de la
curvatura es que tomando al vector
unitario tangente en cada uno de los
puntos sobre la curva tu puedes imaginar
tan rápido estos vectores unitarios
tangentes van cambiando de dirección
entonces podemos llamar a este primer
vector unitario tangente
de 1 a éste de 2 y a este de 3 entonces
todos los vectores unitarios tangentes
piden longitud de 1
por eso son unitarios todos los países
tienen longitud igual a 1
la guía de la curvatura es ver qué tan
rápido el vector unitario tangente
cambia de dirección entonces tú puedes
imaginar que en lugar de que cada vector
esté sobre la curva podemos poner a cada
sector unitario tangente a la curva
anclado pero a un mismo punto así
entonces aquí en otro espacio este sería
t1 y t2 está apuntando un poco más hacia
abajo
t3 está apuntando un poco más hacia
abajo que t 2 entonces este es de 1 este
es de 2 este es de 3 y observa que son
los mismos sectores que están sobre la
curva pero estos vectores están anclados
a un mismo punto tienen su origen en un
mismo punto y eso nos facilita ver cómo
va dándose el cambio en la dirección de
estos vectores queremos ver qué tanto
cambias de dirección mientras pasas de
t1 t2 habrá un cambio grande en el
ángulo y lo mismo para t2 t3 el cambio
será grande en el ángulo entre estos dos
vectores
es una curva que se ve algo así entonces
el vector unitario tangente en ese punto
cambia rápidamente en una distancia
corta formando casi un ángulo de 90
grados mientras que si tú tomas el
vector unitario aquí cuánto cambio si
vas de este punto a este puedes ver que
no cambia mucho entonces en la curvatura
tomamos la razón de cambio de ese vector
unitario tangente aquí t t mayúscula
denota una función que nos dice sobre
qué vector unitario tangente estamos
trabajando y vamos a tomar la razón de
cambio no en términos del parámetro t
qué fue lo que usamos para parametrizar
la curva porque en realidad no importa
como paramétricas la curva por ejemplo
tú puedes ir por una por una curva
manejando y puedes ir muy rápido muy
lento pero la curvatura sigue siendo la
misma en lugar de eso vamos a tomar la
razón de cambio con respecto a la
longitud de arco uso la letra s para
denotar la longitud de arco
y la longitud de arco significa esto que
si yo tomo un pedazo de esta curva así
la distancia de ese pedazo de la curva
en el eje x es la longitud de arco y si
tomamos esa distancia y la consideramos
muy pequeña entonces tenemos un cambio
pequeño en la longitud de arco que
denotamos por de ese entonces es lo que
nos importa cuál es la razón de cambio
de ese vector unitario tangente con
respecto a un pequeño cambio en la
longitud de arco entonces digamos que
vas a avanzando aquí una distancia de
supongamos 0.5 y quieres saber si este
efecto unitario cambio mucho poco en
dirección pero este pequeño cambio en el
vector te dice qué distancia hay entre
la punta de estos dos vectores lo cual
hace de esto qué es lo que nos importa
es el tamaño de esto que es una cantidad
de vector valuada nos indicará cuánto se
curva la curva cuánta curvatura y en la
curva si tenemos una curva más cerrada y
avanza a la misma distancia pero ves que
el cambio entre los vectores es un
cambio considerable
un cambio de dirección grande eso nos
dice que hay una curvatura grande en el
próximo vídeo hablaremos sobre esta
función que opera sobre el vector
tangente y vamos a tomar la derivada de
esto con respecto a la longitud de arco
y bueno para facilitarlo mas debes tener
en mente al círculo que pasa muy pegado
a la curva en cada punto porque bueno
ahí es donde se entenderá tomar la
magnitud de la razón de cambio del
vector unitario tangente con respecto a
la longitud de arco